[Music]
i've been getting really into 3d renders
this year way more than i have
previously and clint
has been doing a bunch of render
challenges that i've unfortunately been
missing out on
thousands of people have been
participating submitting their own
renders and clint has strung them all
together into some
really epic montages the fomo is real
especially this one which is pretty cool
the world's largest digital rube
goldberg machine that sounds way up my
alley come on
i'm gonna try to make a zombie killing
machine so i've enlisted the help of vfx
artist jordan allen to simulate
the zombie horde and then we're gonna
squish him with this
only problem is i've still got my
surgery arm slowing me down a little bit
and
next week we begin shooting son of a
dungeon and that's all day every day so
i have to get it done
this week or i won't be able to submit
it
[Music]
look who it is
we saved your spot for you just like you
left this just like i left it looked
like you left me
i've been here the whole time so nice to
meet you yes you too man
yeah absolutely yo clint so what have
you been up to since you left other than
losing that smash
how am i supposed to just breeze by that
part
oh ren's up in here when i was live
streaming he challenged me in smash bros
like over chat and i'm like dude
you won't come over dude come over here
right now i dare you oh he's gonna do it
too
he came over my house live on stream and
like freaking challenged me in smash
bros
people were jumping in like i thought it
was a render challenge like what is this
smash bros what are you doing
done game
dude that was great what's up with these
render challenges you've done two before
this is now the third render challenge
the first two were more cinematic
challenges when the montages came
together you know match cutting between
all these people through all these
different universes
but this challenge in particular is a
way to create
a large seamless rube goldberg
contraption
with individual artists and it's going
to be pieced together
to form the largest rough contraption on
the internet
basically what i'm providing you is a
box
with a camera movement and you have to
create your contraption within that box
that guides this ball from point a to
point b
there's a number of technical
limitations that need to be met
in order for your puzzle piece your
render to fit into the larger picture
such as when the ball drops in when the
ball exits the scene
so i'm curious what what do you guys
like do you guys have an idea for what
you want to do
i have a video pulled up okay that
was kind of a big inspiration for this
idea the video i'm talking about
uh have you heard of it it's called lord
of the rings specifically it was the
second video
uh like at the battlefield
so this is kind of generally the
inspiration but instead of horses
it's a ball yes and instead of orcs it's
the entire corridor crew that's great
that's great
that's the general idea and jordan has
been basically r d the actual
pipeline to create this which involves
crowd simulations and ragdoll physics
and cinema 4d
isn't particularly tailored for either
of those for sure
however houdini is jordan knows
houdini are you at neo level on i'm no
way
i couldn't claim neo okay so you're like
uh like cipher
i'm still looking at the pills debating
how much can you help us cheat now
cheat yeah i want you to give us
preferential treatment i want to win
that grand prize
give me the prize i'm not whispering
secrets into your ear the whole time
you're doing your writing a good word
you doing this there's no
way you're going to win this thing
disqualified immediately i don't know
so okay obviously we're not going to be
up for any prizes here
but my goal is to get into that top 100
we'll see
we'll see i mean if our thing is good
it'd be really awkward if you didn't
because then
because then you'd have to be like dude
like you wouldn't directly say this to
me but you'd be thinking like
it kind of sucks you didn't put me in
the top 100. you know i'll have to see
that's gonna that's up to you
you gotta make it good enough
sweet all right so i think you guys got
all that um good luck and hopefully
yeah makes top 100 or else uh
friendship's gonna be super awkward
i have zero doubt in my mind i actually
don't believe what i'm saying at all we
actually have to earn this oh boy
all right where are you at with this you
know i got to say i'm kind of nervous to
push play here
i think we're in a good spot yeah we're
we're getting good contact like they're
falling over
they're falling off the ledges like we
want them to so
these guys if a person hits another
person that person's not going to react
to that person
hitting them exactly but i think we can
do that i think we can do that
one step at a time i got to finish
blocking out what is going to go within
this cube and kind of get timing blocked
out as well like kind of get the the
ramps set up kind of get the ball
simulated into place
and that is what we'll kind of bring
into houdini to actually do the rest of
the crowd sims but in the meantime i
need you to basically be the most
pro level crowd simulation expert you
can possibly be
with the time i'm giving you and how
much time are you giving me uh till the
end of the day
fantastic perfect all right i feel like
we're
we're dialing in on the idea there's no
way
there's no way this video is not the top
100.
what i'm trying to do is basically clear
out all the stuff here so that i can 3d
scan it using my phone this room
is going to be the top floor of the
dynamic machine
i'm using the new newest iphone 12 has a
built-in lidar scanner so you can
actually get like
real life decent quality 3d scans these
are real life textures
i want to capture them all the fine
detail and whatnot
why try to spend a whole bunch of time
trying to recreate this detail and i can
just scan it and capture that detail
and display it for all of you that's
pretty sweet it's like you actually see
a bit of a mesh of this room that we're
standing in here
the fact that i can just literally just
take a break from my computer
come in here and turn this room into a
3d model
it's pretty cool what modern phone
technology can do
the scene where i destroyed clint at
smash bros
that is going to be playing on the tv
i think i think we're on to something i
think this is going to be sweet
oh boy we're getting down to the wire
here
it's now friday and this is the day
we're supposed to be done with this
we are actually legitimately preserving
our 3d models
for the next eon last year we 3d scanned
ourselves and preserved our essences
so we got six different character models
each with i think
five or six animations all randomized so
you've got 36 different
possibilities for our zombie corridor
crew so i'm gonna have to try to figure
out how to basically
texture and light this whole scene
i see a lot of wonderous things
happening
what i want to hopefully see is wonder
turn into product
by the end of the day next week we're
shooting son of a dungeon
the most ren's going to be able to do is
show up here with his muscle suit
and his one free hand and like maybe
like click the mouse a couple times and
we're going to like rand get back down
here
this is this is the part where i'm like
cool stuff guys no pressure but there's
a lot of pressure
i'm not sure you have to get the top 100
but you also need to get done today
there's a lot of work ahead of us so
yeah let's get to it
[Music]
so we have a final crowd simulation that
has been
packaged up and exported so that i can
bring it into cinema 40 i've already
tested it it works
so jordan's responsibility through this
whole process is pretty much over now
he's busy this week doing other things
and so now it's on me to be able to
finish this project the problem is that
some of the dungeon shootings this week
this is my sole responsibility for the
entire week
this this week has been six months in
the making
and so this obviously has to take
priority because we've got a whole crew
here
got d in i don't know how you're gonna
do it or what you're gonna do
but watch it all go down in flames nick
what happens if you don't make top 100
if i don't make top 100 i i have to
write clint out of my will
do you think you can maybe bribe him
dude i tried already man like he's just
not having it
my my thing has to be top 100 quality to
be top 100
i mean just put let's put this in the
context there's gonna be like 3
000 top vfx artists submitting their
work people who are like
professionals i'm just saying like you
know it might not be that great
compared to them let's do this
hey clint hey um so
chances of ren uh actually being in the
top 100 of your video i'd say are pretty
low because
i don't think he has any time to work on
it at all this week come on i need to
talk with you too okay clint like i i
get it he's your friend but like
if his runner's not that great you know
probably shouldn't put him in
the top 100. sam see ya
[Laughter]
my first plan of attack is to understand
what this virtual production is going to
mean for me as an actor
i will be in costume and ready to go
film at a moment's notice
the thing about film shoots in my
experience is a whole lot of hurry up
and wait
i can sit down here at the computer but
instead of waiting i'll be working
and action
[Music]
sweet hey that's not bad that looks
cinematic
i finally have a break instead of
finishing this video i wanted to tell
you about expressvpn i don't agree with
a lot of ren's choices today
but i think one thing that we both can
agree on is that expressvpn can give you
better internet security and unblock
content all over the world
am i right you're right okay so the
first thing you got to do is do some
kind of warm-up exercise and i mean
physical
you can do squats okay okay
is that as low as you can go slow as
badgers go
you feeling it no feeling the blood
going through your system
man all right so what what's the first
thing people got to know about
expressvpn ren
it can hide you from the world kind of
whenever you're on unencrypted wi-fi
your information is out there and
vulnerable but with expressvpn
all of your information will be 100
encrypted in fact
specifically your internet service
provider will not be able to see the
websites you visit and therefore
won't be able to sell your information
to third parties the point is
you can unblock content all over the
world ron what's your favorite show
right now
nba finals great and how did you watch
the nba finals
by finding a random stream online and
using expressvpn to make it think that i
was in the uk
yeah i'm not kidding the kid's a natural
see what i mean you know what i do when
i'm here i use it to watch mlb because
when i'm in texas there's certain teams
that i can't watch and then when i'm
here there's certain teams that i can
watch so i just do a little flip-flop on
them and boom and it's super easy you
can use it on any device your phone your
tablet your computer your smart tv and
you can do nba finals you could do
netflix you guys probably don't know but
there's a bunch of
oscar-winning films on other countries
netflix and and you can watch them all
just by using expressvpn
find out how you can get three months
for free by clicking the link in the
description
e-x-e-r-e-s-s
vpn dot-com slash corridor crew
hey he got one part and then you will
get your three months of expressvpn for
free
all right so anyways good luck with the
uh render i hope you're in that top 100
like you've been hoping for
no guarantees though uh-huh yeah see you
later
uh i'm so lost right now you have a lot
of work to do
oh boy i have to literally pull my hand
to use the mouse
i mean
[Music]
it's cool i got it i got it i got it
don't touch my hats you're injured right
you've got two broken bones
just i'll take care of the mods okay
okay you go do what you got to do
[Music]
all right the uh bow or it's the
crossbow shot
i literally did not even have enough
time to log into parsec
are you telling me that you haven't had
enough time to
you're good i've known ren for
10 years i've known that man for 10
years
i don't know how he thinks that he's
going to be able to do all this in the
same day
i know i love that he's enthusiastic
about both of these things i mean
corridor shoot friendship with clint
right it's like two great things
but one of them's gonna have to go
[Music]
wow you got so confident your render
must be
so good i didn't get the the outfit memo
though
show me what you got show up show me
uh here i'm gonna i'm gonna rotate this
monitor
oh so this is what i will be seeing so
now get back over there oh over here
over here i didn't sleep last night
so i am cranky ren this is what this is
what's at stake right now
i cannot confirm that you're gonna make
the top 100 montage today
but i can confirm that you will make the
all renderers montage
if and only if you follow the rules all
right
i'm gonna hit play and then that will be
your cue to come check it out you ready
[Music]
wow
wait wait who
if nest versus versus bowser what did
you do
that's so funny dude this is so cool
this is sick first off nice photo scan i
see you got a nice photo scan of the
room up there
it's lit perfectly i love the way you
did that and then
i love the fact that there's two worlds
to this you have like normal life and
then it's just like
mordor down here it's so cool this is my
subconscious
yeah this is my subconscious okay and my
loss
triggered a just a clear destruction of
my psyche and me as a person
and it's destroying all of me right that
was that was exactly what we were going
for
are you for real yeah we talked about it
from the beginning that was the plan no
way
can you make us a hard commitment right
now for top five it's it's we need it
right now here
here's what i can tell you here's what i
can tell you so far
out of all of the works in progress i
have seen i have not seen any finals
this is one of the best ones give it to
me
come on baby yes this is awesome
this is really well done thank you man
oh yeah and also our friendship
saves oh my god
i'm writing around a letter that he
can't open
until the winners are chosen hopefully
it will it will
ease his soul friend
yes my lord
friend mm-hmm
and jordan this letter here
this letter here is for you
and you can't open it until the winners
have been chosen
so do i have your word not to open this
until the winners are chosen
you do i have one aye
okay here you go thank you hopefully
that'll take care of things
make it super do
you and jordan's render is amazing and
deep down in my heart
you are number one you know what
that means a lot thanks clint yeah
absolutely guys
are we number one on the contest though
like do we actually
get the number one spot like stay tuned
stay tuned
but no joke though this render challenge
is a really fun one and i cannot wait to
see all the final entries
august 1st is the deadline there's still
time for you guys to participate make
something cool make a contraption
it's going to be amazing i can't wait
come on over youtube.com check it out
and let's make some fun art together